are you catching up on TV and movies
that's what a lot of people are doing
we're catching up on stuff we haven't
seen I am I am we're more right now more
movies than TV I'm one of these guys I
just I don't know how it came about but
it happened that pretty much between
1985 and 1996 or 97 I saw four
mainstream movies that's it that was it
the kids I was like hanging out with the
artsy kids so you'd come like you come
to high school and I'm going hey guys I
hit that double feature this weekend of
Unbearable Lightness of being in my
beautiful laundrette hey guys no
spoilers on whitneyhl and I yeah I could
see that I had not seen I had not seen
Dirty Dancing I not seen I have not seen
like even even the kind of mainstream
analyze this crystal I love De Niro had
not seen Titanic had not seen you hadn't
seen Titanic No hadn't seen everybody's
beam tight how can you avoid Titanic
it's they put it on contact lenses right
there's no way did not see Titanic I
just say I was doing a lot of theater at
that time yes it was one of those things
we wouldn't be watching the classics and
it's been really great we've been so now
is the time for me to catch up on those
movies literally jokes people have been
telling for 25 years and I don't get
them yeah now you're starting to get it
I'm now starting to understand like it's
it's it's helpful to watch things like
it's helpful to watch something like
American Pie and go okay I see how
comedy shifting and why that's important
in in that particular genre I like again
it so it's been it's been fascinating
so you finally understand the
importance of the shift to cinema about
having sex with pies right very very
important sub-genre also it's it's been
great because it's you know being on
lockdown with a writer director isn't
boring so we have fun so we've been
we've been we've been doing these things
we're oh so the other night I saw Air
Force One for the first time and then L
had to go do something and so when the
movie was over she came up to me she
goes so tell me how did the cut of the
movie and she'd seen it and so I kind of
just kind of recap'd the last I don't
know hour of the movie in like 30
seconds and then she was and then she
was in this she went wait a second she
said if I if I picked another movie and
we were watching aliens she goes could
you she goes could you recap aliens in
one minute in one minute and so we were
like oh can we do that so then we
started thinking about what would it be
like to make a 100 could you knock a
movie down to one minute you put it
online we did we did we put that like a
lot people are really loving this will
show a clip of it right now cuz it's
really cool let's take a look at this
this is an alien it's a movie in a
minute aliens will you is there any
other one that you're thinking of doing
movie in a minute I mean there's some
that have come to mind and and but uh
trying to think I mean guess we're
having I mean I could probably do I
could probably do like like a rough
Titanic Titanic you wanna give us just a
taste of it I won't hold you know the
whole exact minute thing you know okay I
think I should be able to do it though
let me see if I can let me see if I can
no pressure pressure you during this
time of quarantine the camera all right
here actually hold on you get you
prepare yourself mentally okay
yeah it's a three hour and ten minute
movie I believe and we need to see it in
a minute and you tell me when you're
ready to go I'll give you crazy look at
that late so you got it in exactly one
minute it was three second once you were
done I pulled it in and then I hit stop
so that's probably one minute one second
my question is that was fantastic
that was great and now I never have to
see Titanic again everyone should be
that's that's hilarious
that's really hilarious and also oddly
satisfying I don't know why but it's so
satisfying to see it all come together
like that this much together it's funny
CliffsNotes just me
because brain games is coming up coming
out at Disney Plus and they've gotta
yeah and I got to say I feel like if you
sit down with your kid and you watch
brain games that should go to science
credit for their oh boy this one wanted
to mention I'm a big fan of I've never
achieved it myself but I love it when
something can be entertaining and
actually without you even realizing it
your intelligence grows as your that's
it that's such a hard combination to hit
and that's why I really want to get the
word out on brain games brain games is
gonna be available for streaming on
Disney Plus on April 17th that's
important because that's the day before
my birthday and I know a lot of presents
are coming my way
keegan-michael key thank you so much
thank you sir
always a pleasure